[Music]
this is star talk sports edition
and of course i've got gary o'reilly
gary hi neil
gary is our the only street cred we have
for this programming having been a
professional athlete himself and a
professional sportscaster over in the uk
uh in the soccer realm yes and chuck
nice always good to have you here man
always a pleasure
yeah the one person who has done no
organized sports in his entire life i
mean actually you could have just said
has done nothing
and just left it there
and you and you would have been spot on
gary march is looming and so what do you
have in store for us today
all right um perfect a little bit of
march madness the ncaa's march madness
college basketball is approaching um and
if you work and i'll say this in an
english way and then again in america
and if you work for berkshire hathaway
or berkshire hathaway right
you nail a bracket because it's all
about brackets brackets brackets
you get some of warren's money really
yes who who
he said this mm-hmm yeah so he you have
to be a company employee sometimes they
open it up to the public but generally
it's a close shop for berkshire hathaway
employees only you can get up you can
get a hundred thousand if you do a
decent job
or if you nail a perfect bracket you get
a million dollars a year for life right
in other words in other words play the
lottery people
just
just go with your state lottery
chuck i think i think uh
i think he knows nobody's going to win
that so he's letting you do it and he
ends up with more money at the end
anyway yeah that's my point it's like
you got a better chance of winning your
state lottery than you do of picking a
perfect bracket so that's just it how do
you pick a perfect bracket now if it's
beyond our human brains to to achieve
that and we know warren's a very very
wealthy man because he doesn't give his
money away
so he's holding on to his money but is
there a way is there a way
to break the system break the bank and
get warren's dough
possibly but for someone we need an ai
expert i i know only one person for that
and he's a friend of star talk has
appeared before and that's one and only
dr phil
have to explain that in a moment matt
ginsberg matt welcome back to start talk
dude
thank you it's always a blast to be here
yeah so we call you dr phil because
those in the know know that you
programmed
a computer to solve crossword puzzles
and you named that program dr phil that
was just bro phil f-i-l-l brilliant and
so you've got
how's that working out for you
i i see you making crossword puzzles
just just fine um and actually dr phil
beat all humans and
uh it and i retired from crosswords
well once you've beaten every single
human it's time to go on to something
else right
so
let me get this category out here let me
finish the man's pedigree please
okay he's got a phd in mathematics from
none other than oxford university and i
don't think that's oxford mississippi i
think it's oxford
uk
a scientist entrepreneur author
and
uh your specialist in
in ai especially when it comes to
solving hard problems rather than just
sort of taking over the world and now
gainfully employed at google so what do
they have you doing at google okay oh
well you know i'm building chromebooks
terrible misallocation of resources
that's all i can tell you they brought
me in i'm an ai specialist and they were
like all right we need you to build some
chromebooks yeah because everyone at
google is brilliant he's at the low end
so i actually i i repair chromebooks i
don't get to build chromebooks i'm
aspiring so that a few years from now
moving up
actually building chromebooks i
and in my spare time at google i work
for google x which is a moonshot factory
we basically try and solve
incredibly hard problems any one of
which is likely to fail but between them
all we expect to deliver a reasonable
amount
of useful technology to the real world
so that's a name inspired presumably by
the x prize which is money given to
uh impossible tasks solved by brilliant
people
i i they haven't told me where it came
from
okay it may have been around for a long
time i do
i bet i don't know trust me
i think i got that one squared out okay
i think you probably did and i i just
want to say that all of this
disclaiming you know chuck saying i have
never played a sport i mean he sounded
like he's never even watched a sport
when i was at oxford
i was the captain of the bridge team and
we actually tried to get
bridge recognized as a real sport so
that we could get oxford blues and put
them on our shirts and be official
athletes
they were having none of it
chuck you and i are in the same boat
here okay
well then i'm in very good company i i
feel better
all right so tell me then about
a game theory broadly ai specifically
invoked to
predict
brackets
in in
athletic events and the most famous of
all brackets as as gary said is the
march madness with
college basketball you know when i think
of
game theory i think of
elements of chance and how you can sort
of maximize those to your favor
but
how much do we think of
athletic contests as exercises and
chance
as gary introduced this topic and he
said you know can we use ai
to
build a perfect bracket
and i can say i can just save a lot of
time here no
that's it no
and okay that's the end of the show
thank you very much
this has been a real blast
i think i think what you have to
understand
when you're betting whether you're
betting against berkshire hathaway or
you're betting against vegas or you're
betting against your buddy who lives
down the street
you have an opponent
and
ai can make you
better
but when you try and make a perfect
bracket your opponent at some level is
like god
you're actually trying to predict the
future not better than the next guy but
perfectly
ai can't make you better than god or as
good as god as anything
but
what it can do is it can make you
potentially better than the guy who
lives down the street so that you rate
to make money it can make you
maybe better than the guys in vegas who
are quoting the odds so you go to vegas
and you rate to make money
and i think that's where
we can potentially add value
i don't know if this counts as value we
can make a difference that okay very
important point to distinguish there
just being better than your opponent
versus having all knowledge of all of
creation
you just want to make some money
tomorrow and that's all so could you
explain just in just in as few words as
possible
what
what do brackets mean
just
i don't know why someone who would be
listening to this program would not know
about brackets but just i'm an educator
i just want to make sure we're all on
the same page describe the concept of
brackets
so
the the ncaa
the march madness tournament they're
roughly speaking they're 64 teams
and it's a single elimination so every
game one team is eliminated if you want
to get down to a winner you got to play
63 games to eliminate 63 of the 64 teams
so they divide it and they try and set
it up
so that better teams are playing worse
teams at least initially
and that way the better team sort of
having the easier path and they get to
the end and the better teams keep
playing and if you can predict who's
going to win each of these 63 games
you've nailed the bracket in gary's
terms
if you get one wrong
a team that you thought was going to be
eliminated plays on
and you didn't get the black bracket
right
so if every game were a coin toss
they're asking you to predict 63 coin
tarsas
in a row correctly
and your chances of doing that are you
know two coin tosses it's one and four
three it's one and eight
63 it's one in some giant number that
i'm not even going to try and compute
you can say it it's astronomical say it
say it it's astronomical
thank you so if they have 64 teams you
know normally we see it like as a
diagram there's like 32 teams on one
half 32 on the other half and then they
whittle down and then you have 16 and 16
eight and eight four and four two and
two one and one that so these are this
is the bracketing is that how we can
think about it it is and people people
think of it as the first
you're going to play 63 games the first
32 games are the first round they sort
of happen simultaneously after those 32
games 32 teams have been eliminated so
you've gone from 64 teams to 32
the second round you can play 16 games
simultaneously that brings you down to
16 teams
the sweet 16 then the elite eight and
then the final four and then the finals
and then the winner
but if you know that one team is going
to win you don't care about who else
loses right so why do you have to
predict all 64 games correctly
that's the only way
warren will give you his money
is if you get them all right so picking
who's going to win
that's not so bad i mean at worst that's
1 in 64. if it's random you have a 1 in
64 chance but picking who's going to win
every game
that's 63 coin tosses which is
what i think it's called astronomical
okay i just calculated
uh
the odds if all each were a coin flip
what it would take to predict 60
for outcomes 63 so i get uh basically
uh 2 times 10 to the 19th power so
that's uh a lot a lot
the answer is that's a lot
that's that's uh that's
sorry so that's uh 20
let me get a uh
uh 20 quintillion
is what that is wanting 20 quintillion
so i'm on the right page i'm on a good
page here now so chuck gary you got a
good page yes all right so if we say
that 20 quintillion is just too much for
us to really grapple with
what what would we need matt to to to
understand and comprehend to build a bra
you know a system to
do really well at brackets
is there are there some fundamentals
that you have to bake into an algorithm
to be able to
bring forward
something that would have some success
so my question is what does really well
mean right and this is why your opponent
matters if really really well means
getting it all right and getting
buffett's money
the answer is
pick another project yeah it's just too
hard if doing really well means
getting enough of them right that you
win money in vegas
now we can talk
because now there's all sorts of stuff i
can tell you about
so in terms of why it's so hard
imagine you've got two reasonably evenly
matched teams playing and you can really
predict it you can look at the
individual
match-ups and you can say oh this is
actually going to go really well for
these guys you look at who's injured
but what you don't know
is that halfway through the second
quarter
somebody is going to slip
on a on a little bit of
moisture on the floor and twist their
ankle and be out
you can't predict that but the game can
easily hinge on
so there is just stuff that makes this
more like a coin flip that you just
can't figure out in advance now the good
news is
both teams are probably equally likely
to slip on that moisture
so if you conclude team one is 80 to win
the game then team one probably is about
80 to win the game but if you have to
get 63 right in a row
80 isn't good enough in a minute i'm
going to ask you what an algorithm is
because i think we've we all i me if i
look at it from my own personal point of
view i can say algorithm i know they're
used they're in my smartphone they can
dictate trends from on a youtube channel
all those things but what is an
algorithm
we we talk about it but i talk about it
but i don't know exactly what one is
what you would bake into an algorithm do
you have to have the outcome
set in your mind in advance and then
build it backwards from there so i mean
if it sort of dismantled it like a car
engine what do we get with an algorithm
so
an out an album algorithms are simple
right they're just
telling
an idiot
a computer but fundamentally an idiot
telling an idiot a sequence of steps to
pay
get the answer to some problem a really
competent idiot yes
well it's a it's i don't know the
company they're not computers aren't
really actually that competent you can't
ask them anything sort of coherent but
they're really fast my favorite line for
computers from decades ago was a
computer doesn't do what you want it to
do it does what you tell it to do tell
it to do yeah what you program it to do
and that's not always what you wanted to
do yeah that's what they used to say
garbage and garbage out yeah yeah
so john mccarthy um
was one of the people who invented ai
and he said ai was the attempt to get
machines to do badly what people do well
so
guys you got to take a quick break but
when we come back we'll pick up that
conversation on algorithms but we also
want to know in what detailed way is ai
operating to make these decisions when
star talk sports edition returns
back star talk sports edition we're
talking about bracketology if there is
even such a word we have friend of star
talk matt ginsberg who's all about ai
and betting and winning bets not against
god apparently this was first disclosed
in this episode but against your
opponents so
if you beat god that's a whole other
kind of what else you got cooking in
your in your basement there so
let's pick up the algorithm question
gary where were you where did we leave
off
well
from my own point of view i mean
i look at it i say i i'm familiar with
algorithms but i don't actually know
what one does how it works why it works
um so i just wondered if we had that
seeing as how it's difficult to play god
with an as an algorithm and
produce perfect brackets
maybe we could get matt to just break
down a little bit of what an algorithm
can do and what why it does it and how
it does it and and how can it be
predictive
it's one thing to
have the machine do what you tell it to
do but how do you tell it to predict
something that maybe has not happened
so the thing the thing to remember here
is that
like i said algorithms are incredibly
simple they're just
doing what you tell them to do
i could say
i want you to predict the weather
tomorrow
and if i
lived in
the sahara desert
i could write an algorithm it would say
sunny and hot
yeah every day just say stunning
you'll be fine
but if i live in pittsburgh where it's
notoriously difficult to predict the
weather
you need much more sophistication
and somebody else decides i want to use
this algorithm to predict the weather
the algorithm is just a series of steps
the fact that it happens to predict the
weather is sort of
magical it's what makes one algorithm
better than the other if you decide i
want to predict who's going to win the
super bowl
you need an algorithm you're going to
put in all these steps
and at the end of the day
it's going to generate an answer if the
algorithm is
good
it'll tend to predict the super bowl
winner if the algorithm is bad it'll
predict
randomly but they're too surprising
the two elements of this one of them is
uh are you doing the right calculations
with the available data another one is
do you have all the data you need in
order to predict
with accuracy so
do you know at any given time if you
have all the proper information you're
just not smart enough to stitch it
together to make the prediction
you always know that you don't have all
of the information okay so if you go
back to my example that's that's very
humble
yes
you
you don't know that there's moisture on
the floor
you'd love to know about those moisture
on the floor you'd love to know where it
is but you don't know that
because depending upon where it is on
the court one team is going to be
significantly more likely to get hurt
than the other i would love to know that
i would love to know that so and
was out partying last night and didn't
tell the coach
i'm not going to know that so there's
always a ton of information that is
inaccessible
and the question is how good a job can
you do with the information
that you do have
and as ai has gotten more sophisticated
it has become the algorithms that the ai
scientists produce have become more
capable at
drawing effective conclusions from the
data to which they had access
but they're still just doing a bunch of
specific steps
they have no idea what's actually going
on
they're just
add
register 5 to memory location 37 and put
the result in memory location 84. don't
forget to carry the two you got to carry
the two
an astronomical number of steps like
this that they're executing sequentially
and at the end of the day one of the
steps says
report the answer so they report the
answer and then the next step probably
says wait until something happens and
you're asked another question but
they're just
running
steps now one of the interesting
questions is whether we're actually
doing the same can you take the view
that our brains
are actually just neurons firing and the
neurons don't know what's going on so
it's very curious you know
i'm distinguishing what you just said
for an algorithm duly answering gary's
question from what i think of at least
in my romanticized view of ai where the
ai writes his own damn algorithm and
don't even need you
uh-oh talking about sentience now
this is when they take over
so a division of google
called deepmind
has just produced
code that will write code
and
on the internet there are these
programming competitions where people go
and
they they write some code to solve a
problem that's described in english and
these guys at deepmind have written the
program that actually reads the english
description and produces code
and it's about average
in terms of how good it is for the
people entering these programming
competitions it's about average
i don't again it doesn't know what it's
doing right
does that matter well then it's not
intelligent it's just a fast human brain
doing calculations
let's go back to warren buffett's money
if we're not getting our hands on
warrant this is all about the dough
all right if we don't get our hands on
warren's money what if we take a trip to
vegas with our nicely polished algorithm
are we going to fare any better rather
than try and predict the 63 coin tosses
why don't we just go in there and have a
little bit of a smart move
on that part of the world um because
they'll break your knees
you know what chap
here's my thought if i
my algorithm right i've invented my
algorithm in the garage and i'm really
proud of it and i'm gonna take it to
vegas and i'm gonna be really clever
do you think the guys in vegas don't
have their own garages and their own
algorithms
and so here we go matt if i started to
use an algorithm
to win
against the bookies
will they do they have their own
sentinels their own ai sentinels waiting
for guys like me to turn up
they certainly
if
chuck is sort of right if you start
winning money regularly and in large
quantities
yes they will notice
they absolutely will notice
and they will
be very concerned
i'm not saying they'll break anybody's
knees or they won't but they certainly
will notice i'm going to chuck on this
one they're going to break your house
yeah yeah i'm i'm pretty sure
casinos right not not even right now
because now they're using auto shufflers
to uh make it almost impossible for you
to count cards because they shuffle
after every hand uh with with eight
decks in the shoe but before that
even card counters
they knew you were counting cards
because the eye in the sky was like that
guy right there keeps winning all right
now let's go and focus on him even
tighter and uh let's give him more
scrutiny and so you would have to be
kind of a a manipulative genius to win
enough and then lose enough and then win
enough and then over a period of time
you walk out with the money and and who
can really do that
so there's a distinction here that i
think is incredibly important that
we're not making
and one is and it's the difference
between
beating blackjack
where you are taking money from the
house
and going in and playing poker where the
house is just taking they're raking you
know they're taking a small rake off
every hand
and if you win money you're winning it
not from the house but from the other
players opm other people
other people's money and sports is in
this weird limbo because
let's say that for some reason
everybody and i literally mean everybody
wants to bet on the bengals in the super
bowl
the odds are going to change because the
house doesn't want to
they want to just they want to make
their rake they don't want to be taking
a strong position on who's going to win
the super bowl so if you at some level
to win in sports betting
you don't have to be so much smarter in
the house you have to be smarter than
the other people who are betting on
sports betting they're never going to
find out you're winning they're not
going to come and break your knees
so in sports there is an element of both
vegas does set the line
and if they get the line wrong and you
come running in and you're constantly
beating them because they set the line
in their make a mistake they'll notice
but at some but they're also setting the
line based on everybody else's bet and
at some point you're betting against
the other players as well and it becomes
a little safer
okay
in in march madness and in you know
football as well but any of these sports
betting
you know the the common ones that you
find in the office place
uh it is a redistribution of wealth
right
uh right i bet and i lose but that goes
to chuck right and chuck and i bet and
we both lose and it goes to gary so
so i guess there's there's no
bad will
there because everyone is participating
in this with this understanding but if i
learned that you used ai and the rest of
us are just sort of reading the paper
yeah we're going to break your knees
right so matt
what
parameters are people putting in other
than hunches
to beat their opponent in bracketology
well fundamentally what you put in is
all of the play records from all of the
previous games wow and that's basically
all the information that's available and
maybe you can put in that somebody got
hurt
but mostly it's just all of them play
records for all the previous games so
then you actually can find out
if these two people are on the floor
together
surprising things happen well then you
know that going forward you can find out
this guy
he hasn't gotten any rest the last two
weeks and historically if he doesn't get
any rest he plays terribly so now you
know that so you're looking mostly for
patterns in data that you have that you
sort of the community has agreed is sort
of the starting point and that would
include what teams not just simply
whether they won but what teams they
beat
right that's got to be in there too no
it includes it includes everything it
includes that this guy
made a three-point shot
at
two minutes and 22 seconds left in the
second quarter
it includes absolutely everything and
these are the other players second half
and these are the other players who are
on the floor at the time
and
it includes every you know this guy
committed a foul at this point this is
who else was on the court this guy was
absolutely everything and this date is
available so you can actually get every
everything about
every play
and so forth and so on now
one of the things that typically people
work with play records these days
there's also video
so you can potentially look at the video
and see where does somebody choose from
and and but man there's a difference
between information out there there's a
difference there's a difference between
data
and knowledge
so what you do with that information
might be different from what someone
else does
i guess that's the magic of who whose
algorithm is who's right
that's the magic so the algorithms
process the data to make predictions
roughly speaking we're all working with
the same data
but you'll have some people with better
algorithms and some people with worse
algorithms if people are using vastly
different data that's when people start
getting upset
because they feel like they've been
cheated because i didn't know so and so
twisted his ankle and you did that's not
fair
but when you work with the same data it
somehow sort of seems fair and now it's
really just a matter of
who's smart enough to create the best
algorithms who has the computational
horsepower to run those algorithms
because they're becoming very
computationally intensive
and thereby making better predictions so
the raw material for this neil to my
mind
is the quality of data
because if you've got access to some of
the random things that can happen like
for instance someone was partying the
night before when they shouldn't have
been someone is carrying an injury that
you don't know about that hasn't come
out into the public domain that quality
of knowledge
is what will
enable an algorithm and a builder to to
make a better algorithm am i right there
matt
i think there are
two ways you can win
one is you can have better data
that sort of feels a little unethical
the other is to have a better algorithm
that does a better job of processing the
shared data
a better algorithm means you're now
maybe
i'm a scientist so maybe i just like it
when smart people win a better algorithm
means you were smarter than the guy with
the worse algorithm
okay better data means
you know you followed the basketball
players the night before to see what
they were actually up to and that
somehow just doesn't
seem right it seems like that's an
unlevel playing field and this
you know but
i like it when better algorithms work
because i like making good algorithms
we're going to take a quick break when
we come back to our third and final
segment we'll finish up on that topic
but then we're going to you know chew
the fat
and just get into some of the more
philosophical dimensions of this topic
applying ai to predicting sports
brackets on star talk sports edition
we're back star talk sports edition we
have a friend of star talk ai expert
mathematics
all around math guy
matt ginsberg matt great to have you
back on star talk how do we find out
would you hang out anywhere on on social
media
i have a website
matt ginsberg.com
and that is practically it i have a
twitter account that i never use i don't
belong to facebook
i'm really as quiet as possible well
that means you probably read and do
things with your spare time
i do
transitioning out of the last segment
let me just ask matt before we get into
our more philosophical questions
isn't there this
force operating on who wins that doesn't
show up in the data such as
how badly do they want to win
i wanted it more
exactly and for equal talent that could
elevate someone's performance why is it
that
you can do this best in track and field
that
in big events many people have their
personal best
whether or not it's a world record they
just perform better in that moment under
those circumstances than they ever have
in their entire life
and so something was going on within
them that didn't show up in their
previous data so the last nba finals uh
the milwaukee bucks giannis
whatever his name is because i can't say
it but
uh it's widely held that he
just rose above his game and above his
team's performance to carry them almost
single-handedly to a championship
and you look at bob beeman's world
record setting
long jump in the 1968 mexico olympics
beating the previous record by over a
foot
and and no one came near that for for
decades
so so
i don't see how that shows up in your ai
algorithms it's it is totally in the
data it is totally in the data oh this
is fascinating
throw down throw down here you go go on
so if you
you can look at
the previous performance of athletes as
a function of
whether or not it was a clutch situation
and if there are athletes who reliably
perform better when the pressure is on
that's totally in the data and if there
are athletes who reliably perform worse
when the pressure's on because they
choke
that's in the data and if there are
people who just perform the same
independent pressure
that's in the data
so it's it now it is the case
that being in the olympics is special
being in the super bowl is special but
you can also look at for somebody
for a generic player who performs five
percent better in a clutch situation
how does he perform how much does he
perform better in his first super bowl
that's in the data
not this guy who's about to play in his
first super bowl but i know how this guy
responds to pressure and i have data
telling me how much pressure the super
bowl really is put it all together and
all now this guy's likely to play in the
super bowl wow some people are gonna
have good days some people are gonna
have bad days but
but all the stuff you've been talking
about
it's all in the data so how about the
fact that some coaches give
better pep talks at halftime than others
do
right all right guys listen
to me 212 to nothing
but i'm telling you right now you gotta
reach inside yourself
okay
so what's not in the data
are there's a there's a wet spot on the
floor
okay
or
this bit of astroturf was replaced badly
that's not in the data
all right chuck you had an interesting
philosophical question back a couple of
segments ago what was that
i'm saying like if you
if if you look at the question of
whether or not a
algorithm or computer
is doing pretty much the same thing we
do i'm trying to figure out how it's not
when
if you look at somatic memory episodic
memory aren't we just taking the
collection of all of our
knowledge making associations coming to
a conclusion then making a decision
that's exactly what matt's been saying
so why so matt why are you better at
this is it because you can handle more
variables but so are we right i can
think of you know what is tom brady
thinking when he he's hiked the ball
he's got the whole field in his head the
history and the
he's got it all
and no one is talent there's no adding
machine that you can point to it's
almost at an intuitive level going on in
his head so in the same way he's he's
looking for patterns he knows how to
read defenses he's seeing that certain
guys going in motion or being out of
position means certainly left or moving
right
right why is that any different matt and
why should we trust you and not chuck's
intuition
i don't that's not the
i don't think it is different
and i think you know one of the things
you said neil earlier on you said well
then
why is it intelligence
and i don't know what i don't
i don't know that intelligence has a
meaning
other than sort of a
performance if you can do smart stuff
you're intelligent and i don't care how
you got there
if you can
always throw to the right place you're a
good quarterback and i don't care what
the processing that happened inside your
brain to make it happen
is
now there are some people i think
probably the best known is roger penrose
who actually believe that there is stuff
going on inside of us
that is not computable
that it depends on quantum mechanics and
it depends on this magical relationship
between our minds and the world of
mathematics that a machine can never
duplicate but just a quick it could be
right a quick bio and roger penrose is a
physicist at the university of oxford
who
in fact just got the nobel prize a
couple of years ago for his early work
showing that einstein's general theory
of relativity has to give you black
holes like is it it's a necessary
prediction from the foundational physics
that's there and he's long respected in
physics and in astrophysics then he
stepped into the world of consciousness
and into a world where we really don't
have good explanations so you wanna
those are the kind of places that
attract smart people and he was just
imagining that you know we can think of
the brain as electrochemical but let's
go a step deeper is it also quantum
mechanical and if that's the case then
you're then all bets are off because you
you're not predict the quantum physics
creates a an unpredictable randomness to
it that um may be the source of all of
our wisdom
is that a fair way to think about his
contributions to consciousness matt
it is i mean he was my thesis advisor
and he and i have argued about this and
you have described his position fairly
and what's interesting is i mean when we
argued about this
it didn't take long for us to realize
that we had this fundamental
disagreement is what's going on in your
head
quantum mechanics or is it sort of
classical mechanics that a machine can
duplicate
and we realized we were on different
sides we realized neither would convince
the other i believe chuck appears to
believe that what's going on in your
head you could capture as a process
if somebody eventually makes a real ai
an actually intelligent artifact
then roger will be wrong
if
we keep trying and never get there maybe
he's going to turn out to be right but
right now nobody nobody knows
matt mentioned classical physics so what
he means there is if everything that's
happening in your head is classical
then it means you can point to all
causes of all effects and trace it back
and how they interact with each other if
there's a quantum domain going on then
the cause and effect gets disrupted and
then you can't then classically describe
it but so matt then what about i mean
you're at google what about the future
i'm pie in the sky here what about
quantum computing
will that be able to mimic
what might be quantum influence in our
ability to predict the future
so i don't know
and the right person to ask is roger
because
i actually think we don't need quantum
computing because i think we are
classical
artifacts what's going on our head is
classical
i don't know where
he is on that question um i know you
know google
does quantum computing
everybody's doing quantum computing
these days it's exciting it can break
encryption
um
maybe they're afraid to put you on that
topic because then you might take over
the work
yeah
at least take over google
they're watching the chromebook assembly
line just just to keep you out of
trouble i know i know they um
the chromebook repair line
um
sorry to cut across you if it's data
driven this whole thing about and if we
don't know it we don't know it
do we then not point ai in the opposite
direction and say go and find what we
don't know
bring it back and then we'll build even
better
is am i am i seeing this in the wrong
way completely
i think
that's a great question and by the way
let me interject here what we do when we
send robots to other planets
there often have a serendipity mode
where it looks around and if there's
something it doesn't recognize that
we've programmed it into it
then that is
targeted for extra curiosity
and so but you have to be able to notice
something that you don't
recognize
that's an important step and not and not
otherwise just look right past it so
just pick up matt i just want to put
that out there
the consensus these days
is that
there is a huge amount of scope for
improving our ability to draw
conclusions from the data we have
so when you look at all the stuff about
big brother and tracking terrorists with
data it's and amazon predicting which
book you're going to want to buy next if
you read books
netflix predicting which tv show you're
going to want to watch next
it's amazing how well these systems
perform
it was a huge surprise
all they're doing is they're doing a
better job of exploiting the data we
already have and the consensus is
we should be focusing on
improving our ability to use the data
we've got
rather than looking for more data
when we're not even using our existing
data as well as we could by and large
acquiring more data is expensive it's
hard it's
intrusive
and and i think it's the consensus of
the ai community that there's still so
much scope for doing more with what we
know with what we have
that that's where we should be focusing
interesting that's very interesting
and and and so when you say it's is it
just the amount of
um
work that it takes to get more data
is that why it just gets more invasive
it's you know
it's like
it's like the way netflix always keeps
trying to get me to say please rate this
so that we can better understand how you
and i'm like screw you
i'm not giving you any more information
about me than you already have right
sell something to you better yes
chuck do you have do you have
an alexa
i do i have an alexa i have a google
home and i have um an amazon or whatever
the other thing is i don't use any of
them because the first time i use it so
you think so you think oh no they're
unplugged
so you're fake
well played sir well played
they're tapping into the electromagnetic
energies of the universe
yeah but the first time i used one it
scared the hell out of me because
it it immediately started to as they say
learn
and that was frightening to me
so that is amazon or google or whomever
do you use your cell phone chuck
unfortunately yes and i see it every
time i use it i see the results i see it
come up with the ads that i never looked
for
and then all of a sudden i'm like i
should buy diapers i don't even have a
baby
but then a
chuck you should move your bowels about
now you have done so in the last three
days at this time
and by the way you know uh here's a
great product to help you do that
but go ahead i'm sorry this is the
length that that these companies and i
would now work for one
will go to get more data so matt from
march madness are you are you entering
that contest because somebody's going to
have out of 20
quintillion
possibilities
somebody will come in ahead of everybody
else
because that's how it works and but
they're not going to get all 20 20
continues
to be someone who does better than
everybody else if anyone say well how
did they do it and then they you get a
peek at their ai will everyone focus
around them or we're gonna say it's it's
random dumb luck
hard to know right if they win by a lot
if they're like way better than
whoever's second people are going to pay
attention
if they just edge out the guy who's
right behind them then it was going to
have enough of a luck element that
there's probably not something to learn
but i think it's it is
it is the case that if somebody fails to
get warren's money because they only
predict 62 of the 63 games correctly
that person will get a lot of attention
right if it's marginal then it's just
like emily down in shipping who pick who
wins the pool because she was like i
like the teams with the bright colors
and then it's like
and she beat everybody you're getting an
email from emily
[Laughter]
so i think we this came up in a previous
episode matt with you as a guest
where
if
if everything you say
and if you're as good as you say you are
why isn't this podcast filming you at
your villa
you know what matt's going to say right
now because this is an actual
screensaver that i have
why aren't we on your yacht
why why why are we in some
corner
why what what
i have made my life about solving hard
problems and not about making money
and that is a choice that
i regret absolutely no immensely
that's a choice
absolutely okay it's a choice that is a
choice that makes my wife extremely
upset with me
i have i have had a better life and i
have healthier children because of it
yeah that's probably true unfortunately
definitely yeah
that's pretty special this stuff yeah
you know what though i will say uh as a
as a point of admiration matt that
um
that and that is um philosophically a
much higher position to take no blair
it's a nobler position oh yeah
thank you but mostly it's fun it's just
fun you like to solve the unsolvable you
know the hard problems are we pointing
enough ai at the problems this planet
has right now
why are we finding brackets to
basketball
solutions that's okay let's go make some
money or let's go solve some really big
gigantic problems
are we doing enough the first the first
project i worked on at x
was
to use ai to help decarbonize the
electricity grid okay generate
electricity distribute electricity
without burning fossil fuels yeah
that's as important as it gets that's
really important
and
you failed that and so then you went to
basketball okay
um
i think that
i think that there is
a significant
amount of work spent on these on these
incredibly important problems okay it is
also the case that
if you look at getting a computer to
play chess
that doesn't save anybody's life
but
the work on computer chess moved ai
forward an enormous amount
and allowed people to take what they
learned from chess
and apply it to problems that actually
matter so a lot of the a lot of the
magic i think is probably the right word
of being a scientist is about finding
problems
that are hard but still just barely
tractable
and have the property that when you
solve them you will learn something that
you can take elsewhere
to make the world a better place yeah i
mean you look at the medical industry
which is now where chuck that was
he just he just composed a beautiful
ending sentence and now you got to keep
talking
yeah
okay all right
i was just agreeing with matt but that's
okay this sentence was like you could
belongs on a statue somewhere
okay just go on no no it's just not
just
i was just agreeing with him like you
know the fact that it is it's becoming
increasingly expansive and it's making
life better for so many people and
many other branches beyond and this is
this is what mathematicians have known
forever
that they're
they're an engine of so much uh advance
in culture and civilization in ways that
people don't really appreciate because
the advance is somebody else's invention
based on what they did and the other
person gets the credit not matt but we
love you matt
we got you we got your message
we're gonna start a gofundme mat
so something you said about ai playing
chess right and
that that then inspired people to think
in a certain way
is this the legacy that we're finding ai
is leaving us it's it's making us think
better
think differently and improv is it is
actually teaching us
there's so many things i could say i
mean one of the things that people have
often joked about in ai is that as soon
as anything actually becomes successful
it leaves ai and it becomes part of
autonomous driving or some other
discipline right ai is teaching us about
ourselves certainly um
we are we are learning about what we can
do and what we can't do
my belief has always been that computers
solve problems differently than we do
and they always will
and that's going to mean that we can
solve more problems with machines at our
side
than we could solve by ourselves or they
could solve by ourselves by themselves
and it's tremendously
positive it's tremendously optimistic
they're tools they are tools
and we will be able to do more with them
than we could ever have done without
them
and we should all be ecstatic about that
it's not going to be like the terminator
right it's going to be like
figuring out how to get carbon out of
the electricity grid
on that note we got to land this plane
we got to land this plane oh i had oh i
just wanted one more thing to know
it's not no okay
chuck go make it fast really fast uh
back to it's in the data is it possible
with all the data of every war ever
fought
on this planet
to be able to predict when we might be
going to war and if that war will lead
to our ultimate destruction
probably
okay here we go
and with that
thank you matt for that
succinct reply to chuck's
doomsday question we got to call it
quits there uh matt always good to have
you um chuck gary
pleasure making
this has been star talk sports edition
uh what do we call this we call it
bracketology if there's even such a word
is now
there it is now you've got it i've been
neil degrasse tyson you're a personal
astrophysicist keep looking up
[Music]